the genealogy industry is dramatically
growing thanks to popular websites like
ancestry.com and 23andme it's estimated
the number of people have tested DNA
with those at home kits doubled last
year to more than 12 million our own
Alex Wagner recently researched her own
origins and identity she is the only
child of a Burmese mother and American
father his roots traced back to Ireland
and Luxembourg
Wagner chronicles her search for answers
in her new book it's called future face
I love this title family mystery an epic
quest and the secret of belonging Alex
Wagner welcome to the table as it gasps
thank you it's a pleasure to be here as
a guest and author I have wondered if
your whole life that you've had to spend
your time addressing who you're I
remember the first time I saw you on TV
is she black is she biracial yeah yeah
she what is she Latino what is she and
you tell her great story in the book
that your dad who obviously looks white
had gone to the bathroom and somebody
looked over at you and said are you
adopted someone else yeah
what's your blood yeah I that moment in
the diner was kind of travelator I was
12 so my dad had gone to the restroom
and I was asked by the line cook are you
adopted and it was the first time I
thought oh wait a second maybe everyone
else doesn't see me as generically
American as I understand myself to be
and as I grew older Gail to your point
you know this kind of exotic hot Bob
what a future face right that's what I
was and that was exciting and
interesting and fun but at a certain
point especially as I got older I wanted
that felt to rootless I wanted meaning I
wanted to find a sense of belonging and
identity and that's what this book is
it's addresses white because you said I
like Chips Ahoy Saved by the Bell
I like things that you black people
don't like that you know
I I was raised in a largely white
community I identified more with white
culture yeah and I began asking myself
why where is the Burmese side of my
history where does that where is that
made manifest Alex were you looking for
your place in the American story or in
any story I wanted to find myself
situated in the American story in part I
mean I think all Americans especially
right now want to find themselves in the
American story we're so fractured as a
country there is such a question about
identity who belongs here what is the
immigrant story and how does it dovetail
with the American story that's a
fundamental question right now right and
I wanted to find out what kind of
American am I which means who were my
American forefathers right there is that
cliche we are a nation of immigrants but
what you found is that's the cliche but
it's not the way we live yeah well I
think also a lot is lost when you
immigrate to America and that is partly
by necessity but also because we like to
exfoliate the bad parts of our story and
what I did was go back to the homelands
and find the ugly parts of the story and
write about them because they think part
of becoming whole is accounting for all
the sins and all the warts and all the
fissures that are part of everybody
historians know and you put it in the
book you said my fam my people are weak
dishonest stupid and corrupt yep
hello family yeah we did some bad things
in the pond both sides in Europe and in
Asia and I think it is about coming to
terms with the things we left that were
broken that we didn't just arrive here
on American shores virtuous perfect
immigrants virtuous new citizens of a
country we had our own baggage and and
part of this moment I think is
reconciling that American bag and you
talk about America and defining it as
either a melting pot or a salad yeah and
it seems trivial but it's not no it is a
big distinction because the melting pot
assumes that we all kind of get sanded
down that rough edges are made smooth
the salad bowl recognizes that we're all
sort of different individual people and
different individual ingredients but the
question is how does that all coalesce
how does that all become one thing I
mean that's the fundamental question
we're asking in America we're all so
different we all taste and look and
smell and sound
and believe different things how do we
make a democracy out of that and you
dedicate it to your favorite son your
only son my son or sigh of course
because at the end of the day you said
home is really where you are for that
you know we are so preoccupied with the
future in some ways and we are obsessed
with the past and it is important to
know that the real history of the past
and our true histories but this is our
time on planet Earth that's right this
is our story and I'm all about doubling
down on the press husband Sam was here
yesterday you're here today so I will be
here tomorrow it's finger thank you so
much future face is available today
wherever you like to buy your books